how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
the eternals is
right around the corner only a couple of
months left until its official release
now of course we were already supposed
to have it but due to covet 19
everything got pushed back
but now since we are so close to the
movie coming out there are a lot of
leaks and spoilers coming out about the
film
and today we have some pretty cool plot
details about the film
that gives us more insight about the
celestials the eternals
and the deviants including a major
secret
that the eternals are apparently going
to find out in the film
there's a lot of new information that we
found out in just
a day so let's dive right into it but if
you're new be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest
mcu news i also have some big giveaways
coming up so be sure to stay tuned
so let's first dive into this leaked
plot description
and then we'll dive into the leaked
figures and what their descriptions have
to say about the film as well
this league description is coming from a
merchandising company
redwolf.n and this is what they have
listed
after the events of avengers in game the
marvel cinematic universe will be
redefined yet again with the
introduction of
the eternals heroes from beyond the
stars who have protected the earth
since the dawn of man but when monstrous
creatures
thought lost to history return in the
present day
the eternals are forced to reunite in
order to defend humanity
however erstwhile loves sarzi and icarus
brought back together by the
re-emergence of this ancient
threat discover a century's spanning
secret that will rock the team to its
very core
it goes on to say but who exactly are
the eternals you ask
they are a race of immortal aliens from
a distant planet who arrived on earth
thousands of years ago to protect
humanity from a race of alien predators
called
deviants the eternals were alerted to
the deviant threat by the celestials a
race of cosmic builders whose
fingerprints are on the very building
blocks of life itself
the celestials are titanic progenitors
of life
as we know it these cosmic builders were
expand the vastness of the cosmos
though few in the universe can conceive
the celestial's true nature
their influence is felt in the very
fabric of existence itself
now as i mentioned we do have some major
celestial leaks but let's break this
down first before moving on
now the first part says when monstrous
creatures thought lost to history return
in present day the eternals are forced
to reunite to defend humanity and of
course we know that these monsters
are the deviants and apparently the
deviants have actually been gone for
some time until they re-emerge in the
eternals movie
and the really interesting part is it
says that the eternals are actually
separated and this is most likely due to
the fact that the eternals didn't really
need to be together as a team
since the deviants were gone so at some
point in time in the movie the eternals
will be a part doing their own things
but their job is to protect earth and of
course we're all wondering what exactly
were they doing during the events of
avengers in-game especially since
thanos is in fact a deviant and that
could be what this plot leak is
referring to when they
say an ancient threat is re-emerging it
could be talking about thanos
now of course he is not going to be the
villain of this film but another deviant
is
and probably multiple deviants coming
back as well but here's the real
important part it says they discover a
century-spanning secret that will rock
the team to its very core
now based off of what the second part of
this plot description says
we can kind of tell that the secret is
that the eternals are actually from
earth and that they were humans and the
same thing goes for the deviants they
were once from earth and they are in
some way
siblings to the eternals this plot
description says that the eternals are a
race of immortal
aliens from a distant planet who arrived
on earth thousands of years ago to
protect humanity from a race of alien
predators called
deviants now this isn't actually true
the eternals aren't
immortal aliens they're actually from
earth they're actually humans but the
celestials did genetic
experiments on them this is how it goes
down in the comics the celestial gods
experiment on the early human race and
in doing so they created the eternals
and the deviants but it seems like in
the movie the eternals aren't going to
know that
they're going to think that they're from
a different planet one that the
celestials possibly live on
and the celestial sent them to earth to
protect it to protect it from these
monstrous beings called the deviants
but little do they know they're actually
from earth they're actually humans and
the deviants are sort of like their
brothers and sisters
so it definitely seems like the fact
that the eternals don't know that
they're from earth that the celestials
created them
and the deviants is the big secret
mentioned here
now it also mentions the fact that sarzi
and icarus were once
loves but we also know that she's going
to have a relationship
with dane whitman aka the black knight
in the eternals as well
and a previous plot leak for the
eternals did say that there was going to
be a love triangle
so it seems like we have discovered this
love triangle it's going to be between
icarus
cersei and dane whitman now let's move
on to the figure leaks and we have some
good
old-fashioned lego leaks lego leaks
never fail especially when they come
with
giant celestials in the photos with
major
descriptions today we have some leaked
eternals lego sets and a catalog for
a celestial a couple of deviants and the
eternals a ship
and the one for the celestial actually
offers some pretty big reveals
now the first thing is the title it's in
arashim's
shadow confirming that this is the
celestial arashim areshem is the leader
of the four celestials responsible for
earth
and the description says when cersei
icarus king go and ajax
take on an evil deviant anything can
happen
sarzi transforms matter into anything
icarus has superhuman strength
king go fires energy and ajax
communicates with
celestials irishm the celestial's leader
may even join the battle with a stud
shooter in each hand
now obviously the stud shooter is a lego
thing it's most likely cosmic energy
that a celestial would use
but what this reveals is that ajax can
communicate with
celestials and they can come to her aid
especially when it's a celestial of
earth one who would want the well-being
of earth and one who most likely
assigned the eternals to protect earth
so it looks like at one point the
deviants are going to be so strong that
ajax needs to call for the help of a
celestial
and they show up to help so it looks
like the celestials are going to have
more than a little cameo looks like they
might actually end up in the battle
which will probably be a little unfair
considering the fact that the celestials
created the deviants and eternals
now in the other photos we have a look
at two different types of deviants
one with wings and one running on all
fours
now it appears that the deviants are
going to be able to shapeshift and this
makes perfect sense because the scroll
who are in captain marvel who are able
to shapeshift are actually descendants
of the deviants
and the fact that they can shapeshift is
why we see one with wings and why we see
one running on all fours but the
description for the one with all fours
is very interesting because we learn a
little bit more about some of the
characters powers
it says athena gilgamesh and makari are
under attack from a six-legged
biting deviant the three eternals have
amazing powers
athena can summon weapons gilgamesh has
superhuman strength
and makari runs faster than the speed of
sound
it's pretty interesting to hear that
thena's power is the ability to
summon weapons now she has a spear in
her hand in this photo
and if she's using cosmic energy it
seems like she could essentially summon
any type of weapon
swords spears shields knives perhaps
even a gun of some sort that fires
cosmic energy
athena is the warrior out of all of the
eternals so it would make sense that she
could summon some of these weapons for
battle
and the last one is of their ship which
looks pretty cool and
almost looks like a pyramid and very
well could be a pyramid that they have
in the desert disguising their ship
and based off of what we've learned from
these lego leaks and the plot
description that was just released the
eternals is going to be an
absolutely insane movie one that we've
really never seen before within the mcu
so be sure to let me know how excited
you are for the movie in the comments
down below don't forget to subscribe so
you can stay up to date on all things
eternals and everything relating to the
mcu
like the video if you enjoyed it and for
live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you